breaking the Supreme Court has ruled
that the Biden Administration can resume
removal of the razor wire installed by
the state of Texas so this is them
removing now look at this they have got
a truck forklift basically lifting up
the barbed wire so that people can just
wander in so the federal government has
decided not to do its job okay the
federal government is not doing one of
its basic simple it's a simple job
actually because you know where a border
is you know how to defend it and the
Supreme Court has said okay the federal
government is going to do it Texas tried
to do a little something we're going to
screw you over Texas and you're not
going to be able to do anything either